oh just
welcome to Baywatch just here for the
qualifiers one direction what is this
late third hazy oh you dick you turned
the canals into the next game we were in
lifeguard pursuit oh okay
except there's no such thing as
lifeguard pursuit night night vision
I'm oceanic
welcome to Baywatch our team to the
elite of the elite there's a heart so
love this very Beach come on Pete make
my pecker a little bigger and don't
cover up my front bumper you got it
huge dick big dick we're standing into
the abyss here it's up to us to restore
the Baywatch brand every one direction
you here for the qualifier I'm Matt
Brodie I don't have to try out I've got
two gold medal hey Brody
we still don't get the training begins
at Oak 600 it is nothing you would see
me people your refrigerator very watch
[Applause]
what is that you think we do here
prevent people from getting sunburned
occasionally stop them from drowning
stop it I can't save you if you're being
a dick this is a guy you think it's a
good PR opportunity for us look I get it
the exact wash I'm fast off that ship
and touch him keep stock
drugs murder dead body on our Beach and
it all started when she took over some
people are up to no good
we're going to have to do what they
watch this back the truth is one of you
will probably die you can't have to put
what no I'm the only one that think this
is clearly a job for the police
Thank You blue eyed demon you got one
job make sure swim happy white people
don't drown why does she look like she's
running in promo the reason I believe in
God we gotta go undercover
yeah wonder country yeah little do
undercover
Jason borne and got [ __ ] on me
why are we in the mort's you got to get
some hard evidence what's coming for you
now now we hi
weird I'm playing my dad all three
connectors are empty why'd you pick that
drawer tell it's true it's just a little
dead man's back necrotic liquid Batman
will you stop being a baby
that's it about
you
you